Hello Freak bitches is like in this,
in this fucking gigantic audience full of people.
And this is Leonard Skinner.
The crazy thing is Leonard Skinner came out of Florida before people figured out
Florida sucks.
See?
Cause when I was a kid,
Florida was cool.
And if you listen to this,
you know what the fuck I'm talking about.
If you live in Florida.
Yeah.
Florida state.
If you listen to this,
you know what I'm saying,
folks.
I used to live there.
I lived in Gainesville.
I lived there for a while,
but Florida back then.
What did,
nobody had figured out the Florida socks.
It was like Florida is the place to go to get away from this fucking winter.
And then I'll go down there and then I'll move.
And then we realized like the salted dregs of the Weirdos.
Yeah.
I don't want to see it if somebody had a tee shirt,
because I grew up in Louisiana.
So many teachers said Florida on it.
Dude.
That was when they were somebody's,
you know?
Wow.
They made it.
Yeah.
They're really hang Florida.
Florida to Louisiana looked up to Florida.
Oh,
definitely did because Florida had that coast land head pitchers of sunshine on
their shirt.
That's right.
It's on sunshine.
Yeah.
Have that sign or people sitting out like an umbrella,
you know,
and mark a kid.
They weren't infested with alligators yet either.
I don't think so.
I mean,
we didn't,
you didn't worry about it as much then,
you know,
if he lost somebody to a animal or something.
Back then I felt like it wasn't as big of a deal as it is now.
Really?
Yeah.
And the eighties and nineties if you lost somebody to an animal or an animal
bite,
it was more,
you know,
part of God's plan I think.
Whereas now it's like just something crazy that happened at Disney world,
you know?
It was like the biggest thing ever.
Yeah.
That little kid,
that's pretty fucked up.
It is a monster living at Disney.
This is how collar and people get,
they get so silly.
They're like,
well,
he is here before us.
This is,
he's probably a 17 year old alligator and this is made lives.
This is peaceful environment.
And he made my eight a baby.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
and you gotta be a nasty alligator.
If you sit in there and you get this,
probably been other choices came by,
you know,
there was probably a couple of,
young lovers that were out there by the water earlier and you waited.
You know,
you might not get a young lover though.
A young lover might fight back and there's two of them.
That's true.
I don't know.
Don't worry though.
They're pretty invulnerable and if you cut off an alligator's arm,
it just grows back.
That's gangster.
That's as gangsters gets.
Go ahead and chop it off pitch.
I'll see you in a month with a new one.
Dude,
that's the,
that's the two pocket.
The animal kingdom.
Really,
when you think about it,
two fingers full of bullet holes headed to the ambulance and he's throwing up
his fingers and how gangster alligators that their arms are so short and they're
just so capable.
Man,
I'm sure you've seen the video of that new one that they found in Florida that
is on a golf course and it's like 15 feet long.
It's one of the biggest gators over film and these people are on the golf course
then looking up.
But this gator,
excuse me,
could find a Jamie.
We can't show it on youtube.
You have to find it on youtube because I got that cut be pulled off Facebook.
There's something happens when you have these animal videos in particular,
when they go on Facebook,
like people own those videos.
So when they go to uh,
look for,
uh,
they have like an algorithm,
I can find it.
And if it's on your page,
I'll pull your whole page down.
Yeah,
they own this.
But so this,
so many films,
there's a couple of different angles.
I it a bunch of people filling because it was so crazy.
So these people are all playing golf and they're in the foreground so he could
see him like there it is.
Look at that fucking thing.
Yeah.
The look at the guys are real animal.
Huh?
You realize how big it is when you see a guy now watch how this guy walks in the
foreground and the guy,
when the guy gets a little,
doesn't it?
It looks fake.
It looks fucking gigantic now.
Now you see how big it is.
Now you understand how big it is.
Could you see this guy like are you a,
are you kidding me?
And they estimated it's somewhere around 15 feet.
And did they catch it?
I don't think so man.
They found it again.
They found that again in a pond.
See if you can find it.
Um,
they,
they re rediscovered this a alligator in a pond.
I think that was the,
um,
I hope,
I like the title of the video.
Maybe they're making a comeback.
Dude,
I hope something good comes in attacks at some animal.
I'm ready for it.
Everybody to fight.
Don't fight alligators,
man.
You don't want to fight them.
Well,
I'll get out there and do something,
man.
There's this dude that I have a,
I've had on my podcast before,
but he said his name is Jim Shockey.
He's a very famous hunter from Canada and they hired him to go to a,
a certain river in Africa.
I think it was the Congo,
but I'm not sure.
It might've been the denial.
Anyway,
he had to go,
he went down there at to kill some crocodiles that were eating people.
It is one of the craziest videos,
man.
You'd go there and the,
these,
these villagers like everyone's got to stump,
right?
Everyone's missing an arm or a hand or they got chunk bitten out of their chest.
It's crazy when you look at these poor people and they're all just living in
fear.
And while he was down there,
a woman got taken.
Oh yeah.
They were up river looking for these killer crocodiles to try to shoot him.
And uh,
one of the women was washing clothes and she just got yanked right out of the
water.
God,
that'd be the worst to what was really scary,
man.
And seeing the readout laundry.
Oh yeah,
right.
Just he'd wash underwear.
Seeing the reaction of the people that were wailing,
just wailing,
crying,
you know,
because it wasn't just like they lost someone.
It's like,
God,
they lost another person.
It's like,
that woman's gone now forever.
She was consumed,
consumed by a monster like that.
That is their actual existence.
Damn.
Sitting by a river that they need.
It's water for life and the water is infested by monsters who are actually
actively targeting them for food.
Yeah.
God crazy.
That'd be like if somebody's like there was a killer in Walmart and they just
didn't know who or where.
It was constantly like lions would jump out while you were eating at Walmart.
Yeah.
What were you buying?
Food.
Ethylene.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we got it pretty easy man.
You know those people must be so interesting like people that live under that
kind of pressure,
like their view of life and we can understand their language.
I bet they have like a,
you know like you'll listen to like read like ancient works of literature,
ancient poetry,
stuff like that.
And you think about it like these are people that are,
we're going through a war like the ancient Greeks and the ancient Romans.
Like you would read their words to go,
well,
this is fascinating.
We know it's being translated.
This is the words of someone who's gone through like sword war.
Yeah.
Back when they would fight with arrows and shit and swords and catapults and the
intensity of life.
Back then when death was just around every corner,
it was everywhere.
It must be so,
so intense to talk to someone like that.
You should fly in a pygmy or something.
You thought about that?
No,
but I have,
um,
had my friend Justin Wren,
who has been with the pygmies in the Congo is for like many,
many years.
He goes and builds wells for them.
Why?
He's over there for months at a time.
He's had malaria three times.
He's got to come out again soon.
He just texted me.
I got to text him.
We're going to find a date.
And I used to be in the wishing well,
I used to be in the well business a little bit.
Not uh,
wishing wells,
mostly the,
not water wells,
but I worked for this.
This is made by a pygmy in the Congo out of a nail.
It's a little knife that a Justin brought me.
Wow.
Yeah.
They,
they take these nails and there's one over there to see that nail right there on
the desk.
That's what it looks like.
The Hammer,
these nails out and they turn them into knives.
See that starts out a nail that they find a why and they they pound it down and
sharpen it and turn it into a knife.
It you'd have history came back if history struck back to we would,
I wouldn't make it.
I wouldn't meet with Megan.
I wouldn't make it long.
Ah,
you'd be fine.
I don't know.
I'm not prepared for ball.
You would be though.
You people are adaptable.
You're smart dude.
Theo Vaughn,
I would lead,
I would think a little bit.
I would to death.
I'd lay low in the beginning.
Yeah.
You know,
like somebody doesn't pick my battles.
Dude.
You'd have to kill somebody immediately.
You have to find the first person in your group,
the week person and kill them in front of everybody else.
Yeah.
Like you can't just stand there.
He can't kill some dude.
Well think about that man.
You can't stand there and is be in a comedy.
You know everybody's chatting group huddle and everybody's like,
you got to take somebody out right then cause that's going to show your
dominance a hundred year.
I mean it's going at least going to show like this dude is going to do
something.
I see what you're saying.
But I think if you think ahead,
you would think,
well no,
then they're going to think that he's got arbitrarily gonna always kill the
weakest person.
Eventually it's going to get to know one because there's going to be,
the next week is person.
That guy is dead now and the next week like who's to decide whether or not
you're weak or you're not weak.
If you were going to do that,
the person wouldn't have to be either a terrible person who is victimizing other
people.
Right.
Or they would have to have attacked first who'd have to be,
or they would have to have been such a piece of shit that people were rooting
for you.
Like somebody who was real chatty and you just asked them did.
There's no way I'm so kind of survive like,
uh,
like uh,
you know,
the second coming of of the universe and some dudes chatty and my group,
Bro,
that's not,
especially if like he fucks up some hunting parties.
You're out there with sneaking up on a pig and he's like,
oh my God,
it's so hot out.
You fucking the pig runs away and everybody's hungry.
Yeah.
Sadie would be the first man I think about that kind of stuff.
Like if a plane crashed,
I already know I'm planning ahead.
Did I'd eat a Vietnamese guy.
Wow.
Cause it's easier to start or move if you attack somebody bigger.
If you eat somebody bigger in front of other people,
it's going to alarm people.
But you,
you gotta eat a small person.
So stature is important.
I think if you come down a Viet,
people aren't gonna be that upset at you.
What it means people are going to be super upset.
What are you talking about?
Tony's dad.
Yeah,
their sacrifice.
They're more understanding of things.
Dude,
this is a character you're playing.
No,
but if you eat a black dude,
you eat a black lady and her family's there,
they're going to be pissed.
So you think at Vietnamese person,
we'll let you slide.
I think that they'd be much more forgiving over a couple of day period.
I think,
uh,
like our relatives.
You don't think so?
Honestly,
one thing,
no,
I don't think so.
I definitely think there'd be super pissed at you,
especially modernized ones.
But what is interesting is like Vietnam was one of the few places where,
um,
Americans can go back to Vietnam and they don't seem to hold any grudge at all.
Exhibit a
exhibit a man.
Honestly it will.
Asian people in general are just much more forgiving and understanding it seems
like after like,
I think,
I mean I don't have much,
I think that's a giant generalization.
It probably is.
You know,
I mean I did a fast for like four days and then it was at the best buy and um,
and I'll remember this Vietnamese guy was trying to help me out and I couldn't
even hear him.
I was so hungry and I couldn't ended up fast for four days.
You're trying to prove,
I don't know,
man.
I was probably just dealing with some stuff and I'm just trying to find a
different way to handle it,
you know?
Right.
Um,
and then I remember this Vietnamese guy and I remember thinking,
if everybody turned the other way for a second,
I could eat this young fella.
His name was Ben actually over here in Westwood.
Um,
but,
and I'd never thought,
God,
it's so ridiculous.
Well,
I mean,
but here's the thing.
I never thought that before.
So you only thought you got to the verge of cannibalism after just four days.
Yeah.
Damn.
How much weight did you lose?
I probably lost about four pounds pounds.
I needed to know,
but I got clear,
man.
I could,
and I could hear,
swear to God,
y'all could hear somebody fold a piece of bread from 80 feet away,
bro.
I was so hungry,
dude.
I could hear a fucking skittle hit the semen across the street.
I really could,
man.
Yeah.